المترجم: Salih Ahmed
المدقّق: Muhammad Ramadan
في مترو الأنفاق
عندما نريد أن ندخل
يجب علينا أن ندخل التذكرة
يوجد بوابة الكترونية
وشرطة وأشياء أخرى
في المطارات توجد كاميرات
وتوجد أنظمة مراقبة
وفي كل مكان
توجد أشياء تحدد من موجود
في كل مكان في المطار
في البنوك
في كل مكان حولنا
توجد أجهزة مراقبة تحدد اتجاهاتنا
وهي التي تحدد حركاتنا
إذن هذه الطريقة ، هل هي مكلفة؟
فيها تكلفة مادية لكل هذه الأجهزة والأنظمة
ونحن نظل نعدل فيها ونحسن ونظل نراقب
لكي لا يخطئ شخص أو يخرج عن حدوده المسموحة
إذن، هل هناك طريقة يمكن أن نستخدمها؟
وتكون التكلفة أقل ؟
(أممممم)
نعم ، يوجد
توجد طريقة غير مكلفة،
غير مكلفة ماديًا نهائيًا.
هي مكلفة معنويًا
تحتاج إلى جهد وتعب
وتحتاج إلى أن نعمل عليها
نحتاج لنعمل على الرقيب الأخلاقي داخل
أي واحد فينا
رقيبنا الداخلي، أي نصبح نحن الكاميرا،
الكاميرا التي تحدد تصرفاتنا
نحن الجهاز الرقابي الذي يحدد
السلوك الذي نتبعه
في مترو أنفاق ألمانيا
كل أجهزة المراقية عبارة عن خط
مرسوم على الأرض
مكتوب عليه إن تعديت هذا الخط
يعني أنك تمتلك تذكرة
هذا هو جهاز المراقبة
أنت فقط
لو أنت تعديت الخط،
هذا يعني أنك تمتلك تذكرة
يوجد طبعًا في القطارات مفتشون،
ومفتشون يأتون فجأةً
وقد يغرموا أي شخص غرامة
قد تصل إلى 500 يورو
لأنك قررت أن تتعدى الخط من دون
أن تمتلك تذكرة
هذا هو الرقيب الداخلي
إذن ما هي أول خطوة نحتاج لنعمل عليها
لننمي هذا داخلنا،
نحتاج لأن نكون مؤمنين بالفكرة
نحتاج لأن نكون واثقين منها.
توجد شجرة في الصين اسمها شجرة
الخيزران
هذه الشجرة تأخذ وقت طويل لكي
نستطيع أن نزرعها،
المزارعين هناك يزرعون هذه الشجرة
لمدة أربعِ سنين
أربع سنين لا يظهر منها فوق الأرض
غير جزء صغير بهذا القدر.
لكنهم يظلون يزرعونها، ويضعون السماد
ويرونها، ويعملوا عليها طول الأربع سنين
من غير أن يروا منها أي شيء
بعد أربع سنين وفي السنة الخامسة،
وفي خلال مدة من 3 إلى 5 أسابيع،
هذه الشجرة يصل طولها إلى 90 متر.
إذن، كيف استطاعوا أن يكملوا؟
ولم أكملوا؟
أكملوا لأن بداخلهم إيمان،
إيمان داخلي يحركهم
ويخبرهم أن نتائج عملهم ستظهر
ستظهر، في وقت صحيح أنه ربما يكون طويلًا
لكن توجد نتيجة إيجابية ستظهر
من بعد هذا العمل
المحرك الأساس كان الإيمان.
في مهذبون الذي حركنا كان الإيمان
الإيمان بأن الرقيب الداخلي
داخل أي واحد فينا
هو الذي سيصنع التغيير،
هو الذي سيحركنا ويوجهنا،
كل منشور على صفحة مهذبون
يطلع عليه 3.5 مليون متابع
هو مجرد رسالة إيجابية،
وسط طوفان من السلبيات التي نراها كل يوم
حاولنا العمل على أشياء كثيرة
حاولنا أن ننظر ونحاول أن نغير
نحن في الحقيقة لا نعلم،
ولم نأتي لنعطي دروس
نحن أتينا لنتغير كلنا،
كلنا نريد أن نتغير، كلنا نريد أن نكون أحسن
وتغيرنا نحن، هو الذي سيغير المجتمع.
كذلك من ضمن الأشياء التي عملنا عليها
عملنا على الشباب، وعملنا معهم في الجامعات
وعملنا في كثير من المدارس
وكان هناك سؤال دائمًا ما يطرح،
هل يا ترى في غياب أجهزة المراقبة،
في غياب كل وسائل المراقبة في كل مجتمع،
ما الذي يمكن أن يحدث؟
لو كلنا سألنا أنفسنا هذا السؤال،
سنعرف أين نريد أن نصل.
في السبعينيات في نيويورك،
انقطعت الكهرباء عن كل نيويورك
وبالتالي كل الأنظمة تعطلت،
ما الذي حدث؟
ما الذي حدث في دولة كأمريكا في ذلك الوقت
الذي حصل فوضى عارمة من الجرائم
أعلى جرائم في تاريخ أمريكا وتاريخ نيويورك
سرقة لكل المحلات، والسوبرماركت،
وكل مكان
هذا في دولة من دول العالم الأوّل
لننظر إلى مثال آخر في زلزال في التسعينيات
في اليابان
أدى لنفس النتيجة
ماذا فعل الشعب؟
الشعب ذهب إلى البقالة وأخذ احتياجاته
ووضع حسابه وذهب بالرغم من عدم وجود أحد
رغم أن البلد لا توجد بها كهرباء ومهدمة
لكن هذا كان التصرف
هذا كان التصرف لأنه كان عناك رقيب
في الداخل هو الذي يوجهه ويقول كيف يتصرف
في اليابان لديهم حصة للأخلاق لكل الصفوف
في بداية دخول الأطفال للمدرسة
حصة أسبوعية لتعليم الأخلاقيات والسلوكيات
لكي يصبح أي شخص يتحرك في المجتمع
وبداخله الرقيب الداخلي خاصته
بنفس الفكرة أو قريبة منها
نحن حاولنا في مدرسة في 6 أكتوبر
أخذنا منهم خلال فصل دراسي كامل
نعطي حصة كل أسبوع
لأطفال الحضانة في الأخلاقيات والسلوكيات
النتيجة كانت رائعة، رائعة من الأطفال
ومن تغير طريقتهم ومن التأثير عليهم
النتيجة كانت رائعة من أولياء الأمور
الذين بدأوا يتابعوا وبدأوا يشتركوا
نحن كلنا اللذين سنكون أساس التغيير
لا يوجد شخص غيرنا سيغير
ولا أحد غيرنا يتستطيع أن يوجهنا
نحن التغيير ونحن الحلم الذي نحلم به.
شكرًا
(تصفيق)